this
is kings field its masterful game design
paved the way for the from software we
all know today and if you enjoy dark
souls it's a game you should know about
to better understand the foundation of
souls king's field was from software's
first video game series their first game
ever titled king's field was the
japanese playstation's first rpg their
second game also titled king's field but
technically king's field 2 in japan was
the international playstation's first
rpg
it also happens to be one of my favorite
games of all time
and the reason why from software is one
of my favorite companies of all time
this is just a cool camera trick that i
saw my co-worker kurtu that i wanted to
replicate
uh don't mind me though
while from software is notorious today
for hitataki miyazaki's genius and the
soul series and beyond what i find
fascinating is that so much can be
traced back to the very conception of
from software way back before hidetaka
miyazaki ever worked for the company now
let me know if any of these design
concepts sound familiar to you
you start in a location with branching
paths there are definitely routes you
shouldn't take and are far too difficult
for you but the game won't hold your
hand and trust the player to discover
for themselves the correct path to go
meanwhile it's actually okay to travel
these paths if you can accept the
challenge
there is a story but it's not completely
spoon fed to you and you'll have to look
at item descriptions to get a fuller
picture of what's going on there are
locations with hidden traps that have
been set for you which you can also
utilize against your enemies
the game is notoriously challenging and
forces you to figure out the mechanics
yourself
there are a plentiful amount of hidden
walls and truss falls onto hidden ledges
with both secret items and weapons for
you to find in other words secrets that
are actually meaningful and exciting to
get
your weapon attacks are slow methodical
meaning you feel the weight of your
weapons
you have a stamina gauge and can't just
repeatedly attack without some sort of
negative repercussion
the world design is interconnected and
you'll find looping and branching paths
as well as shortcuts that bring you back
to earlier points in the game
while i've been showing footage of the
soulsborne games all of these elements
are right here in this little gem
so let me rewind and give you the exact
same speech
but with king's field footage
you start in a location with branching
paths there are definitely routes you
shouldn't take and are far too difficult
for you but the game won't hold your
hand and trust the player to discover
for themselves the correct path to go
meanwhile it's actually okay to travel
these paths if you can accept the
challenge
there is a story but it's not completely
spoon fed to you and you'll have to look
at item descriptions to get a fuller
picture of what's going on there are
locations with hidden traps that have
been set for you which you can also
utilize against your enemies
the game is notoriously challenging and
forces you to figure out the mechanics
yourself
there are a plentiful amount of hidden
walls and truss falls onto hidden ledges
with both secret items and weapons for
you to find in other words secrets that
are actually meaningful and exciting to
get your weapon attacks are slow
methodical meaning you feel the weight
of your weapons
you have a stamina gauge and can't just
repeatedly attack without some sort of
negative repercussion
the world design is interconnected and
you'll find looping and branching paths
as well as shortcuts that bring you back
to earlier points in the game now while
i can tell you this and show you this
it's better if hiratake miyazaki shows
you himself
this is just a random paper i decided to
use as a prop
kingsfield was the beginning of the
demon souls project i wouldn't go as far
as to say that we had king's field in
mind while we were making demon souls
but of course i think its world probably
formed one of the bases for the newer
game however if you're asking if it's a
successor the answer is no
of course there are parts of the game
that are inspired by king's field but we
were very much aware that we wanted to
make a new title with demon souls let's
toss aside the soul series though
because i really want to focus in on
what makes kings feel so special to me
in my opinion king's field is a master
class in good game design while it's an
rpg you'll never need to grind in order
to be able to progress and while some
people might like grinding and there's
nothing wrong with that i do think it
shows a proper awareness of balance
similarly while it's an rpg as it has
action elements that means you can still
overcome a level deficiency with skill
another pointer i want to harp on is
that its secrets are incredibly
meaningful when i say king's field has
interesting secrets i mean that you'll
literally find yourself mashing axe as
you rub up against the wall hoping to
find a secret door hidden chamber there
are chambers similar to sen's fortress
with trapped walls hidden doors chests
that contain skeletons instead of or on
top of loot doors that drop enemies
behind you pendulum maces and more that
you can take a risk and choose to try to
explore despite the scary fact that you
run a high risk of dying to any one of
these traps meanwhile there are chambers
you can drop into with hidden items that
are dead ends and unless you discover a
mechanic for warping out which is never
explained to you that's it you're
literally trapped with the question of
how do i get this thing
similarly there are truss balls you'll
encounter that lead to secret areas or
items oh and you can die from fall
damage so when i say trustfall
i mean it and while all of this makes
exploration fun to do there's an
important factor to it the majority of
the time if you take one of these risks
you'll be rewarded with an interesting
item and i truly mean something you'll
probably want to use whether it be a
weapon a cool spell a key or some type
of special use item i tend to overuse
this example but in many of the zelda
games your reward for exploration is a
box of rupees and while that's fine a
lot of times you won't really need or
want it however in king's field i've
never found myself annoyed at the reward
i received for exploration and while
you're not always rewarded you usually
are and it makes it that much more
meaningful
on top of that some of the secrets are
[ __ ] cool in one instance i found a
painting that said locked but couldn't
find the key
so i attacked the painting which killed
the painting and ended up being the way
to unlock this particular secret in
another instance a merchant was blocking
my way to an expensive item
rather than buying it from him i pushed
him out of the way by constantly
stabbing him stole it and then found it
was no longer for sale the game actually
took into account this random mechanic
of being able to slowly push npcs by
attacking them you'll find standard
puzzles where you shoot fireballs and
light lamps or perhaps minecarts you'll
have to jump off of in the middle of
your ride to find another hidden secret
then there's the map design the
labyrinth of my personal favorite
kingsfield games kingsfield one in the
us and kingsfield for the ancient city
are genuinely interesting with plenty of
unique areas you'll find you'll also
often find yourself exploring deeper
into an area that feels genuinely
intimidating and oftentimes will take
you out of your comfort zone but in a
good challenging kind of way
on top of that they often wrap within
themselves with surprising shortcuts and
secrets you'll unlock that show just how
smartly interconnected the map design is
then there's the music unlike many of
the modern from soft games kingsfield
has consistent music playing throughout
the game which is atmospheric and spooky
these tracks add to the mood and creep
factor of games that honestly
graphically don't hold up that great
outside of ps2s the ancient city in fact
i often use these tracks in the
background of my soul's lore videos as
ambiance since they suit the mood of
those games just as well then there's
the moonlight greatsword many of you
will know this from demon souls or
perhaps dark souls or perhaps the
bloodborne dlc
but the moonlight greysword first
appeared in the japanese king's field
and has become somewhat of a mascot for
from software in fact it's even made an
appearance in armored core and i bring
this up because a lot of the dna of from
software goes all the way back
to king's field it was a niche game made
for a niche audience just like demon
souls but like the souls games it
tackles that niche with a degree of
excellence now look
maybe i have some rose tinted glasses on
and i'm overly nostalgic about the game
but
every time i go back to replay my
favorite kings field games i fall in
love all over again
and that's not true of every game and
the thing is i am so glad from software
has finally been discovered so to speak
because it's not just king's field
inspired by king's field from software
also made the shadow tower games which
share a similar design philosophy to
king's field only even more challenging
as your weapons now break on top of that
they created the armored core franchise
which has for the longest time been one
of the best mech series out there now
not every game by from software has been
a masterpiece and admittedly i haven't
played all of them eternal ring was okay
ninja blade i hear is anything but good
however
in my humble opinion from software
deserve to be on the map before dark
souls blew them up and i'm glad
i'm glad so many people finally
understand how incredible this company
is and how amazing the games they
develop are i'm glad they're able to
continue to make amazing games and so
excited that they still maintain an
uncompromising vision to their games
hitataki miyazaki has taken the spirit
of king's field and brought it into
demon souls and dark souls
although
i still want a new king's field
thanks so much for watching me ramble
about a game that means so much to me
graphically speaking i know it can be
rough for many but i truly think the
core design of these games are
impeccable and i just want more people
to know about it
anyways this is part of a series of from
software videos we're making in
preparation for eldon ring so make sure
to come back for more from us at
gamespot and from myself
[Music]
you